it was honestly it was honestly so crazy
so pretty much
bones sticking out right did you feel it
did you feel it or was like the
adrenaline more like no uh initially
it's a shock you know it's like
adrenaline whatever
but I think everyone was in such a panic
because we're already trying to get out
we had to still hike a bunch
how far were you from Camp I we have no
idea I'm guessing it was like 30 minutes
damn yeah this podcast is brought to you
by raycon earbuds I don't go anywhere
without my raycon earbuds because I love
music and I love podcasts if you're
listening to this podcast on your walk
you should do it with your raycon
earbuds because the charge lasts forever
they're super compact super light and
the sound quality is great for the price
because guess what a lot of earbuds
break your bank for
not the price of what raycon gives you
and for the quality that he gives you as
well I love my raycon earbuds ready to
buy something small with a big impact go
to buy recon.com brain today to get 15
off your raycon order that's byracon.com
brain to score 15 off by raycon.com this
podcast is brought to you by better help
my friends for those of you out there
that are working on your physical health
there's a new year go work on that
mental health as well just fill out a
brief questionnaire to get matched with
a licensed therapist and switch
therapist anytime for no additional
charge if you want to live a more
empowered life therapy can get you there
visit betterhelp.com jeans today to get
10 off your first month that's
betterhelp help.com genius NBA fans it's
time to bring the Hoops action to the
palm of your hand with DraftKings
sportsbooks and official sport spending
partner of the NBA this week new
customers can bet five dollars and win
two hundred dollars in free bets
download the app now and sign up with
the code genius new customers can bet
five dollars on the NBA and get two
hundred dollars in free bets instantly
only at DraftKings sports book an
official sports betting partner of the
NBA with code genius minimum age and
eligibility restrictions apply void in
Ohio see show notes for details in five
four three two one what's up everybody
welcome to another episode of the [__] I
love my dreams
to another episode of The Genius brain
podcast or every Sundays at 12 p.m
everybody and their mom has a podcast
but nothing like this we have a
reoccurring guest here we have Sergio
[Music]
let's go baby I don't know who he is he
is my barber the man cuts my hair met
him through
um Maverick Maverick that's right I
can't believe I forgot his [__] name
apologies been into this guy Maverick
ever since then he's been cutting my
hair he cuts Tim's hair now too yup
thank you for that
it's been good times man update people
on your life man so last time I was here
probably like over maybe a year ago I've
been your Barber for two and almost
three years holy [__] man it's been a
long time crazy bring that mic a little
closer to you and then drop it down a
little bit perfect there you go yeah no
three and a half like almost three years
since covet essentially right yeah and
it's been it's been a crazy ride you've
been aware of it since we've talked but
since I've been on here man just now I'm
not going to be at the same place I've
been cutting for I told you about that
that's been a big one and I think I
didn't even have my girlfriend at the
time either so you didn't have a
girlfriend either this man settled down
and [__] yo life 180 but who got that
disease One China baby
it was cold yeah I know it's been it's
been a blessing honestly like since
since a year ago when I filmed this or a
little over a year ago man I've done a
bunch of murals I've still like
progressed in my art career
um and just like kind of had more
clarity with what I've wanted to do so I
mean you're very interesting because
like I know how do you know I'm 26. I'm
sorry super young right and I feel like
a lot of younger people are very uh risk
adverse right yeah and I know it seems
nowadays that people around your age
they seem like they're doing riskier
things but they're really not right
they're kind of like
they're on social media trying to hope
and pray that they pop off on this like
social media game and more often than
not they fail at it because the success
rate is actually very very low crazy
right it's really really low for you to
actually make a decent living off of
this and
um like just to warn young kids before
you get into this like this is a this is
a job right so you you have to put in
work you have to put in the time and I
think a lot of the times like they see
other influencers who
they'll post a Instagram video them like
in Belize or you know Spain like living
my best life but then I know these
people and I go oh but they also live in
a studio with like three other people so
they got this trip paid for that was
free but it was a [__] coach flight
and it was free food but they got to go
back to their shitty existence back at
home because they didn't get paid off of
these brand deals so like it's not like
that for everybody right you know
they'll make a few hundred bucks here
and there and but I think that's why you
kind of see a lot of young people lose
their mind really [__] early in the
industry yeah yeah they'll snap super
[__] fast they say the same things
just every time I meet them they go oh I
don't really have a lot of friends here
it's the first thing that they say and
they go la people are fake and I'm like
okay there's a couple of things right
like
yeah one and two are true maybe true
right but number one you came here to
network so you didn't come here to make
friends so people will step on you and
use you because you are trying to do
that to them they just did it to you
first literally literally you're coming
in here you're like exactly that's LA's
notorious for that they it spits people
out it takes people chews them up spits
them out so that's like one thing um I'm
like very clear about is like I've seen
it I've talked to people all of that and
it really does seem like really hard and
so I think that's why I really
appreciate our conversations and I'm
able to like kind of like formulate
ideas through you or like um or like
pass them through you and see what you
think but yeah you take you definitely
take a lot a lot of risks right like
which is a good thing right so you know
for most people who are entrepreneurs if
you don't know it's like
um especially for us because we don't
come from a lot of money yeah there's
other entrepreneurs who are serial
entrepreneurs but they they have money
so for them if they invest into a
business or they they switch gears they
have this huge pile of money or they
have a family who could back them up
after and then pick them up exactly but
for people like you and me we have to
just Bank on ourselves you know Make It
or Break It literally
since the start of this since you've
known me you met me at a in a barber
shop right
I had just came into that shop about a
month of work new city relocated 40
miles from a situation that we're gonna
talk about later yeah
um and then covet hit no work
and the first thing I do getting out of
covet is like yeah I want a big ass art
studio in Los Angeles
Loft with a private Barber area private
living space whatever and it wasn't
smart you know I naturally it was not
smart financially everyone was like what
and I was just like I don't know I
really feel it
I I I know I have what it takes in terms
of my first skill barbering I'm gonna
use barbering to make it in my next
skill because you have to like fund your
own projects if you don't want to be
someone else's [__] you know so I was
like how would you say that you became
successful as as a barber right because
I feel like there's a lot of people who
say that they they want to cut it or
they can cut hair but you know I've had
a lot of [__] Barbers yeah you know it's
crazy man because I think I fell in love
with barbering completely on accident
and
I really didn't see anything coming out
of it more than making my money back I I
started in high school senior year
second semester on um my one of my best
friends Bryant he let me or he was
actually trying to leave to go get a
haircut when I drove my ass across town
no gas money senior in high school no
job none of that I was like you're gonna
leave when I got here hell no pull out
the Clippers cut his hair
um I have clips of that even and yeah no
I I secret I messed them up but secretly
I was like damn
because at the time like now barbering
is kind of glorified piece of social
media it isn't it isn't that like people
have to understand the the grind that
comes with barbering right but yeah
basically started bot Clippers
um all the money I had as a senior
bought Clippers and just told my mom my
dad was like man I just want to make my
my Hundred 150 bucks back that's all I
wanted out of Barbering besides that I
just wanted to have fun yeah dedicated
hours and hours of watching YouTube
videos without actually practicing I
know every step without even doing it
essentially right yeah so when I had my
hand when I was able to get my hands on
someone and like chop them up
I quickly like just did it and it was
just like flowing happening and I I've
always been like someone who likes to
like talk to people I'm not a
superficial level and so I think I
opened the space up for people to like
not only get a good haircut but maybe
talk about some [__] or talk about
nothing either or I think just having
that aspect of customer service being on
time being like very like on schedule
I'm
just those things in barbering were
missing when I came into it and it
allowed me to just like keep growing
whether it was in the dorm bathroom
where I started people were like oh this
guy's serious he's here cutting while
other people were walking with their
towels not giving [__] and I was just
like dude I think that's the biggest
thing right and when anybody opens up a
business there's there's
I think a lot of people think about the
idea that they want to do first rather
than executing the things that are
really important that'll make a
successful business right so for example
we have a I have that matcha store out
in Hawaii yeah
and the first thing that we do is it's
not so much that we're vetting our
competition we just want to see what we
can offer that other people aren't
offering yeah not from a product base
right because there's a lot of places
that'll offer Macho right
um it's and you know from the idea point
we go okay this is
our our business model is that we want
to give people high high the highest
quality thing they can afford for the
price yeah right so we make things very
accessible because when I was a kid if I
wanted nice things it was way out of my
reach I couldn't afford it right it just
wasn't possible so what a lot of people
don't know is that oh we have this
proprietary blood of matcha but it's
from a 100 plus year old Farm it's it's
stone ground all this other stuff we
know the ins and outs of every of every
little ingredient that comes out but
you're not gonna pay the price that you
normally would at another place because
if another place branded their stuff the
way that we did they would sell it for
like 13 bucks so much [__] cup and we
eat a lot of the costs so people don't
know that
well they don't know but you you went to
that matcha Farm yeah we doubted it yeah
we went to the farm we did everything
like we the r d process was [__] hard
and then the the other step that we have
to do is see what we can offer in terms
of service right so
you know the island is very chill right
and sometimes you can get kind of sucked
up sucked into that so for us one of the
biggest things that we always want to do
is offer great customer service and then
on top of that offer your drinks as fast
as we can at the same quality level so
just because the island is super chill
it doesn't mean that our service is
going to be like that yeah you know so I
think that's the part where people mess
up like my barber before you this
[__] sometimes would never hit
me back up on text and he's like that's
the only way he gets clients but for him
I felt like he got really comfortable
because he has a set amount of clientele
and he'll respond back whenever he wants
but it's like or I could just not give
you business literally that's another
thing Barbers are so big on oh you're
cheating on me oh you went you have to
understand
it's a mutual like agreement I'm cutting
your hair they're paying me like it's
it's not a favor it's not doing anything
it's not a favorite yeah guys this thing
Barbara young Barbers right now that's a
mentality it's not a favor another thing
is don't just jump in and expect to get
paid like x amount of dollars for
whatever like you have to earn your time
or earn yours your place you know it's
crazy that that thing happens when
barber shops a lot no shows like just oh
bro you showed up like I have one person
still I'll get you in like 45 minutes an
hour dude that happened to me so many
times and it's I think that's also like
for people out there who are going to
open up your business like when you have
Management in place at a store they set
the culture of the spot and then I could
see by the people who's running the
barbershop how much they don't [__]
care like I've literally seen people
come in and they stand and it's like
they didn't have an appointment right
but they're checking out a barber shop
and they want to see you know what the
prices are whatever and I'll see a
customer stand there for 30 minutes and
they won't address them at all
and then all of a sudden they go hey
what's up man what do you mean I hate
that it's been half an hour I hate that
I've seen it before I actually was
taught from a very like
bit like business oriented Barber
um in terms or my mentor the first
person who believes in me took me in a
shop when I was just like 19 years old
his name's Josie The Barber on Instagram
as well he put that in very very made
that very clear
customer customer service customer
service we were quick we like had a um
crazy like client turn around very like
um PRI the price was affordable all that
stuff he he made it so people were aware
like if there's a kid in the shop don't
say things that are like offensive to
the mom or whatever like so many things
that I just picked up from him and I
actually went to his second shop and
what you said culture
I thrived in that Barbershop because I
got to start from scratch and that
barbershop boomed in like a matter of
months the it was in San Dimas it was
like
it was insane to see what proper culture
does for a place I think a lot of people
get comfortable and they feel like after
a certain amount of time that they could
just kind of let go of the reins and
then just say or do whatever they want
but at the same time like if you are a
business owner out there right and
like I kind of tell this to our
employees it's like when we have a drink
store we're not selling a drink and I
always tell them and people usually
always answer this wrong they go what do
we sell here they go we sell we sell
um high quality matcha drinks uh that
are accessible true but wrong we
actually sell customer service
people come here because they want to
feel special right I'm not going to go
to a store spend my hard on money
especially in this economy and not be
treated with respect yep right and I
know that in in America it's a little
extreme but either way I I do expect
people who work at stores to treat
people with kindness and respect because
they're coming here to spend money and
even in a barbershop type of
relationship it's like like you said
you're not doing me a favor
I'm paying you money like exactly yeah
you know it's a problem because it feels
so friendly yeah and it's and of course
there is relationship but at the end of
the day it is business yeah is business
like any other place and I think me
taking it like that treating like a
business is what grew me I traded it
seriously I think that's what I
appreciate too like if I texted you or
if you have a system set up I know that
I can get my haircut done on this day
without a doubt and sometimes like if a
haircut goes over you always text me
immediately it's like hey it's going to
be like 10 or 15 minutes I'm like cool
that's all I just have to know it yes
you know it's so simple like another for
anyone that might be seeing that's a
barber knowing your times if you know
you're about to take this much extra
time let your client know because 10
minutes doesn't matter
that much but if you let them know it
matters even less yeah they'll be
prepared they'll go to get get a drink
or go or leave their house 10 minutes
later it's those little things to do
little things man it's it's valuing each
other's times like imagine if a client
shows up late that pisses Barbers off
how could they be so hypocritical
um to not get upset when they're like
pushing their clients time back you know
100 and that's what this goes back to
those small things that kind of make you
successful as an entrepreneur it's it's
everything that everybody just glosses
over they go oh I have a great product
so does everybody [__] a house dude
it's like yeah if you don't have the
basics done like for example no great
company culture right you're not
training staff properly
um customer service is trash all that
stuff doesn't matter I know restaurants
who arguably not even arguably factually
have terrible [__] food right but
they do well you know why because the
customer service
and I still go back because I want to go
back and be served you know with that
one waitress that was so super nice yeah
you know I've experienced that exact
thing my favorite waiter ever was at a
TGI Fridays this guy's name is Logan she
had a lizard
Mohawks the best server I've ever had in
my life I gave him like triple the price
of the check yeah I was just like how'd
you do this how did you get this out of
me
did you do this dude yeah it's my heart
even too when you're a waiter or like
when you're a waiter or a waitress
like ask the best waiters and the best
waiters how how important customer
service is and how big their [__] uh
tips are compared to everybody else it's
right because if the tips were something
for you that you felt that is deserved
to you just because you worked you're
you're never going to do well I know so
for example I know a guy who owns a
French restaurant right really popular
French restaurant and
I mean I don't really know I met him a
couple times through friends right but
when we were sitting down reading and
drinking and chopping it up he pointed
at a waiter and he was like how much do
you think he makes
and he was like his head waiter I was
like
um I don't like I don't know because I
never served tables and he's like just
guess I was like oh maybe like maybe
like four grand a month or something
like that he goes he makes more money
than I do
he goes I own this restaurant he makes
more money than I do that I was like
this is tips he's like he's my best
[__] server so whenever he comes he
goes we're also in a very very
highfalutin area so people tip big
there's a lot of actors and actresses
whenever they ask for a table they ask
if he's working that fool makes
ridiculous amounts of money and he was
probably I want to say I mean he was
bald and he had white hair so I'm
assuming but he looked kind of young in
the face so I'm assuming he's probably
like in his late 50s at the time yeah
but you know if people are wondering
he's like welcome he didn't get another
job
he makes more than the [__] owner
literally yeah he makes more money in
tips on a weekend than I will than
running this restaurant
which is [__] nuts that is nuts yeah
no it really customer service in terms
of business is everything yeah so
everybody does that based on [__]
tips like there was a because imagine if
you're at a very
um a restaurant with a lot of was every
dish is like [__] 40 or 50 bucks
right your [__] bill is like a
thousand dollars you know people tip 20
that's 200 bucks and sometimes people
tip anymore if they're celebrities and
especially if they just like the service
exactly so if he's out here on Melrose
at this super super fancy restaurant he
was telling me I can't remember the
exact number but I think it was like a
weekend he'll sometimes make like three
grand
exactly and then you know he'll work
like two I think if they say he worked
like three weeks out of the out of the
month and a week he'll take off but he's
killing it damn but that's what I'm
saying like these small things really do
matter man and like when you when
anybody out there who's very interested
in opening a business just think about
what you want to offer and if it's not
great customer service you're going to
be [__] specifically in this country
it's gonna be tough that we've got
Karen's in this world no literally
literally man and it's it's it's
accustomed here for tipping you know
like so it just shows what service means
to this country you know and I know I
seem like I'm very harsh and Brazen but
when it comes to these stores like I
never argue with customers I don't do
any of that type of stuff because some
people are just out there to [__] you up
so for example when we open up the store
in Hawaii and there was a whole bunch of
trouble with that my buddy Joe kind of
cataloged everything in his own Vlogs
there was a day that we had to do a
family and friends event and so when you
don't have all all your paperwork and
ready the only thing you can do is serve
it to family and friends you can't
charge anything you can't make any money
it's illegal okay so we told our train
our trainees to like hey bring your
family and friends and we're going to
have you guys guys do a mock run and
this is the time for you to make
mistakes but have a good time while you
do it well there was this guy that comes
up
and of course he is of the wahite clan
white people he comes up and he's like
oh I'm friends and family uh can I get
you know a few drinks and then we have a
list of people oh so who are you related
to or who's your friend he goes one of
the workers okay oh my God and like I
didn't have to deal with this but I'm
hearing it from a distance right and my
friend's part my My Buddy Joe his wife
is dealing with this she goes oh who are
you here with and he goes well I can't
[__] get a drink and he just snaps at
her and when he's lying to steal from us
and he's getting mad at us but at that
point too once again we're in a business
of customer service what am I gonna do
walk up to me like listen back the [__]
up before I knock your teeth out which
is what I wanted to say you wanted to
yeah no they're just like sorry we can't
we legally can't give you any drinks or
we'll get in trouble he goes well [__]
it then and he just walks off it's like
bro what are we gonna do here and the
the great thing about it is because I
have worked in customer service I sold
suits or whatever but you always tell
every employee listen it is not your job
to defend my
it is your job to walk away like you did
a great job and to give good customer
service if I have to lose some money on
drinks I never ever want you to be
stressed out over a customer I don't
want you to be here miserable because
you had to somehow get 32 cents or a you
know a seven six or six dollar drink off
of this guy like I'll eat the cost I
don't want you to be upset as employee
because what's the point that is so big
for for employers too because that's
something a lot they lack in the
industry a lot of employers will put
that weight on the employee and you'll
see the reaction of the employee your
employees now they know and they're
clear about it they're just gonna be
nice sorry it is what it is because
you'll run into a few [__] every
hour then right and I do believe most
people are really kind right
um and occasionally we'll get you know
some [__] person that walks in and
they just want to stir [__] up and this
is what they normally do at every
business just to get free things well
guess what I don't want you to argue
with them if it becomes an issue then
we'll then we'll deal with it but at the
end of the day I I just I think when
we've worked these jobs before I think
one of the things I hated the most is
taking my stress home with me oh it's
horrible it's terrible dude it [__] up
it [__] up your personal relationships
it [__] up how you you might treat your
girlfriend yes you know that's one thing
I'm like very clear about because I've
seen it I've seen it firsthand and
friends family whatever and it's that
that's one thing I keep at my core as
well is just like I've told my
girlfriend like
really key to like leave it at the door
walk in and it's like you feel good you
like have this new life found energy
when you walk in home if you have that
mentality yeah did you ever did you ever
fix your ankle
I mean it's not fixed but
I had a surgery on it and no it's not
it's not fully mobile what's your
Mobility on your ankle check it so this
is
that's like where I used to be able to
do it and twist
oh [__] yeah bro dude it why do you
think I can't trade flip no more oh my
God
my ankles were bad dude no like I used
to have crazy Mobility when I used to
skate I used to be able to flick it like
double flip triple flip
and
that's [__] crazy so dude this one
has a crazy story that he told this was
just casually like cutting my hair again
casually just kept telling my hair and
I'm sitting here like what the [__] did
you just say happen to you so he has
limited Mobility on one of his ankles
because he just tore it to [__]
shreds uh on a hike right was it what
was it in Joshua Tree yeah so it was
October
2019 Joshua Tree it's regular camping
with friends right
um and and this is actually why I live
my life the way I do basically we go
camping Good Times the next day we're
like bouldering around and
my homies they they know or at least one
of them knows Josh tree like the back of
his hand he's been there so many times
that we go off Trail
he knows the rock formations he knows
where we're at whatever
it's getting closer to sundown
and there's this big rock it's probably
like six seven feet and I because I
skated my whole life
I was like I could I could do this I
I've never done anything like like I've
never hurt myself so I jumped from this
big rock onto like the smaller rock the
problem was the gravel that was on it
it's like loose gravel that you can't
really tell
I land my like it was close to the floor
so my foot I'm pretty sure anchored into
the floor slid anchored and all my
weight
just crunched up and like Snapped it out
right here
and so like I just hit the floor and
just came up I was like whoa and just
from the sheer reaction of my friends
they were like or one of them
specifically his name's Andrew runs up
he's like
I'm like oh [__]
and looking and bone is sticking out
that's [__] disgusting yo
my head off
it was honestly it was honestly so crazy
so pretty much
bones sticking out right did you feel it
did you feel it or was like the
adrenaline more like no initially it's a
shock you know it's like adrenaline
whatever
but I think everyone was in such a panic
because we're already trying to get out
we had to still hike a bunch
how far were you from Camp I we have no
idea I'm guessing it was like 30 minutes
and so everyone's freaking out there's
like this situation that went down where
I basically told everyone just like go
get help get the [__] out of here go get
help I'm good I'm chilling whatever
you're so good under high tense
situations I would have been like listen
all of you carry me because there's
enough people here that could carry me
all the way back if you leave me you're
dead to me yeah though so pretty much it
was a specific situation that that makes
it's okay basically everyone leaves
you're bleeding out in the wild what
what could possibly go wrong here
I have a white claw
I have my air pods
and I have a hoodie
it's like a white car yeah I had a
singular White Collar left we finished
our water deep like an hour before so
I'm like damn this is crazy I'm really
just chilling and as the sun's going
down oh that's the worst in the desert
it goes down quick 30 minutes later
pitch block
nothing you can't see [__] fancy [__] so
I'm like wow this is really what it is
just I was I was very calm still I was
like this is really what it is and I had
to think like we don't have reception um
on our phones until like deeper out so
they have to hike then drive call an
Ambience try to find me off Trail
so I'm just like chilling there
wow this is crazy it's October 29th or
October 26th of
um that means desert is what cold cold I
have shorts on a t-shirt
surge this is the worst this is actually
worse than what I remember dude yeah
because I didn't get into full details
so we can really go into depth here
pretty much shorts and a t-shirt drops
to 40 degrees
I'm I'm just I actually had a very
intense situation that I I only have
like spoke about a few times one of my
close friends that day exactly a year
before got into a motorcycle accident
and he he had his right foot amputated
from it
but and sadly like during a surgery like
leading up to it
he he actually passed so it was like
yeah it was a really intense situation
he had a black surgery or just it was
just it was it was something with um
trying to trying to drain some fluid and
it was like he was just [__] up from
the hole Yeah he was supposed it's just
such a tough thing like rest in peace
Cowan but um I kid you not this is like
some out-of-body [__] I was
laying down and I remember
I was in like in the sky
I'm talking to this guy and I'm like
[__] out of here yes and it's like
what are the chances this happens
exactly a year later like this guy was
like my big brother
and I was just like my right foot bro
like what do you what was he saying he
was just like you're gonna be fine you
gotta make it you're gonna be good
you're gonna you're gonna be good and I
was just like yeah I'm not I'm not dying
out here [__] that you know like I was
so adamant like oh I got us like it's
not it felt it felt like I got us and
it's just like imagine
pitch black and it's just beautiful like
stars and you can just feel his like
energy right and I was just like
I from this day forward
I was so thankful to just be fine and
like still like I had such a positive
attitude about it I was like I'm gonna
live my life to the fullest so this is
so like okay so your friend who who died
just visits you and you're just like
what's up bro it literally felt like
that bro it literally felt like that and
it's so ridiculous
I I don't know it was just so compelling
that I was like I'm fine I I didn't care
about anything besides the fact that I'm
gonna be fine I'm gonna be fine and so
it really gets intense I think
like it was like about 30 or 40 minutes
in I hear noises around me
and it's known for like there's there's
Mountain lines coyotes and like everyone
says like how many coyotes could you
fight off I'm like three but with one
leg like you're [__] you're pretty
good yeah I probably lose like one or
two you know so I'm like
[__] dude this is intense so I'm gonna
get into detail I'm like in a valley
almost
I would scream like
whatever and it would just not project I
know it's not projecting past these big
ass rock formations
and I'm like damn dude my only my only
chance is getting higher for like for
like safety from like animals I I think
so like I don't know I'm not like an
expert but I'm I have to get higher
and I have to get my voice to project so
that someone could hear me just in case
you know
so I grabbed my ankle and I remember
touching this part of my ankle and it
would go like this oh God it was crazy
damn it dude my phone was like this bro
like completely to the side and I was
like
I remember what happened was I tried to
get up
and so when I went on all threes I like
collapsed because my foot flopped and I
was like oh and I'm sweating just
tripping out of that pain it hurts so
much when I would make movements so I
was like it is what it is and I freaking
get my foot straight I get the hoodie by
the arms and I throw it over and I make
my foot straight with it and then I
start getting the arms and wrapping the
arms and I just tie it so tight bro to
keep my arm or my leg like this
yes to make a splint bro I'm about to
[__] throw up that [__] okay there's
only a few times that I've ever seen
somebody snap their legs and it wasn't
in real life it was because of the UFC
Anderson Silva snapped his [__] leg
Chris Weidman slapped snapped his
[__] that [__] is so disgusting like
every time I see it it makes me want to
Yak your bone bro she headed the [__]
out I won't show you the bone I'm gonna
show you the hoodie I have a picture of
the hoodie right now
pretty much bro I gotta see this [__]
yes this is about to blow your mind
November
dude I've never showed you the hoodie
picture huh no you haven't and you're
gonna send me that [__] I'm gonna put
that [__] in the video Jesus I'm gonna
put it in the video that's [__] it's
crazy I don't know if I I'm Legit if
they would have left me I would have
cried I'm like did someone would
somebody stay here with me please it's
so bad it is so bad
yep
bro that's so much blood
it looks like you got shot
it was so bad I'm gonna send this to you
right now but yeah what was your pain
from a scale of one to ten when so when
I had wrapped it up I tried to crawl on
threes so I had to figure out how to
move right when I crawled on all threes
my toe my right foot trying to keep it
backwards up my toe tapped and I heard
like screeching and I fell over to the
side I was like heavy breathing that was
like 10. ah that was [__] that was legit
well I'm gonna send this to you it was
legit
a 10. because I tapped my toes and I
tried it again because I was like and so
you know what I had to do
because I didn't I I truly didn't
believe my friends were gonna come back
because
or for a while just because it was so
ridiculous like I didn't know how far
realistically that hike tried to find
paramedics whatever whatever and I
wasn't hearing any helicopters or
anything I'm like
[__] dude I'm out here alone they might
be like trying to I didn't know if it
was like so bad in deep into Josh street
that I wasn't gonna get found so I was
like and you just go and you go and so I
proceed to go like backwards like this
with my foot in the air
and like look I have like scars from
crawling
oh [__] and because there's like it's
it's like cactuses all these things
right
I'm crawling backwards guess how long
how like
10 minutes I crawled for like probably
two hours two or three hours bro I
crawled uphill because you know I had to
get my voice to project past the rock
formations so I'm crawling backwards up
this hill
and it felt eternal
I finally made it I remember when I made
it to the spot and it also helps that I
had just seen that movie 138 hours or
whatever I was like oh I'm not gonna die
this guy this guy was stuck I'm not
stuck I'm not I'm gonna make it you know
but I remember I got to the freaking
spot it was this big rock
and um and it had like a little divot of
sand against it it was Flat Rock big
rock David of sand I was so I was
genuinely wholeheartedly prepared to
bury myself in the sand and just to get
warmer right I was like how cold was it
do you think it's 40 degrees oh [__] 40
degrees and I I was just like
at this point I was so used to like my
leg it was it was comedic almost I was
like I can't believe I'm living in this
because
a month before that I saw that movie on
a flight I was like this is crazy man
like I'm glad I saw that movie it gave
me hope and so
right when I'm like okay settled in oh
and mind you already had Drake The White
Cloud before I started crawling so I was
just like chilling listening to your
music
I remember I was like listening to music
I was like all right I'm just gonna
scream a few more times and then I'm
gonna try to sleep and someone's gonna
find me in the morning they have to yeah
so I was just like
help a few more times with my flashlight
and then I hear it
oh [__] and I'm like no [__] way they
they they're gonna get me and so it took
forever because it was so far away but I
was flashing my lights and I'm in good
spirits I see like a light flashing and
also I wear glasses and then I have my
glasses so I'm like what am I even
looking at I'll see like things from far
away lights and slow slowly
um they came closer and sure enough it's
my two homies Brandon and Michael
and two firefighters hiking back and I'm
Smiles bro
ear to ear Smiles my friends are crying
yeah they're like I legit thought you
died
I thought that you died something
happened like what and they saw where I
crawled to and they're like how the [__]
did you do that how'd you do that you
know and I'm like oh it's good guys I
had to take my earbuds I'd be like
here's their music I was like how else
am I gonna crawl for two hours
legit
oh my God I don't even think I told
anyone that story until like years later
because it was so intense you know but
essentially the the firefighters come in
shoot me up with fentanyl instantly like
a body of like war or like a like a
little like blanket of warmth covered my
body I was like oh [__] I had uh not
fentanyl but what's the other one
morphine and I remember I just felt
nothing like it just feels like the
moment they it goes into your
bloodstream it just feels like a warm
blanket just went over there I felt
chill yeah that face right there
perfect
I feel happy
it was crazy I was just like very much
so posted whatever and I thought I was
great then they hit me with uh
we forgot the splint stuff so they had
to like use my shoes to make a splint it
was like all janky at least jackasses or
whatever and then they hit me with the
biggest shock
oh yeah we're gonna call an airlift oh
[__] I was like no you're not you think
I have money for that I was like I was
like there's four of you I have four
limbs we're hiking out here I've been
here three hours I don't care I'll be
here another three hours yeah before I
pay thirty thousand dollars yeah right
thankfully it's included in the National
Park budget oh really easy services oh
my God call the chopper right you're so
funny like even you're about to die
you're like nah dude my immigrant soul
and Carry Me Out [__] literally
a fireman your buff is [__] yeah and
then it was crazy because I was excited
I was kind of died for the for the
airlifts right pretty much
uh the the intensity of a helicopter
floating above you in the desert I was
just like what the [__] happening
whatever and I'm like okay
um they bring down I thought it was
going to be a bed to lay on
these [__] through they they
brought down would look like borat's
swimsuit oh my God it's a harness one
one piece in between your crotch and
then a two-piece above your your
shoulder dude I'm so scared of heights
yeah yeah
[__] out no you know what was worse
for getting lifted by your Gooch
we're big boys
that was I was like chilling chilling
and as it goes
it goes lift oh I'm like
bro I put it down it's more painful than
the ankle brick Oh My getting lifted by
like it's like no you just kill me they
were my [__] just killed me now I I
actually include that clip in my video
that my YouTube video I'm dropping you
just see me spinning
slowly like up it was like from like the
Twitter of the sheriff's department they
have a night vision mode rescue shot and
you could see my hand trying to like go
and just I wanted to get some fingers
yeah and I remember looking at the
person holding the Rope because they
didn't bring me in they just held me
outside for five minutes I'm like
looking at the desert floor below me and
now I'm just like
yeah and then it's like this I could see
this girl through this like Call of Duty
mask
she's just like
you know she's like you're in so much
pain right now so much pain dude you
just reminded me of this [__] funny
story so my cousin told me the story
once where so he has really weak
shoulders okay uh he dislocates his
shoulders pretty easy I remember playing
basketball this whole did a lamp and his
shoulder popped out
and it happened originally I think
because he was wrestling in high school
and it dislocated then and ever since
then the ligaments have been super weak
so he tore it uh it popped out during
basketball doing a layup back that once
when it was like cold during winter and
he tried to pull his blanket off it is
hard to suck so
so he went snowboarding one time
and when he was snowboarding he hadn't
been before and so I don't think he knew
that people were being really sarcastic
because he's just trusting everything
that everybody says so the person who's
more experienced I'm going to take their
advice and do whatever they tell me yeah
so as they're snowboarding
um I think it was it wasn't the bunny
slopes it was one above it okay right
and he was asking them okay so how do I
stop because oh you just crouched down
and then you [__] it and so you'll I
think they're joking but he didn't know
that they were being sarcastic so as
he's on these slopes he's never really
snowboarded before he crouches and he's
starting to get picked up that's how he
gets me so he's getting hell going hella
fast he's freaking out so the only thing
that he could think about is I have to
touch as much surface as I can to make
sure that I stop so he goes down belly
first but he's going so fast that when
he touched his arms
his shoulders popped out it dislocated
his shoulders
tumbling down [__] up right so one of
his friends
you know goes down to see him and he's
like dude are you okay what he's he's
funny I dislocated my shoulder and I'm
[__] up so I didn't know that this is
what happens but a medical team came but
they're not going to get him out with
the helicopter because he's not that far
from where he has to be so they put him
in a harness and like a sled and they
strapped him to it and there was a skate
person that took him down yeah the
slumps but before that happened
there was one person that left ahead of
him to go get help yeah well this guy
didn't come back with any help and so
they had to send somebody else out so
this all said that he was like in it
wasn't like a hospital bed but he was
like laying down they have like an area
for people get [__] up
she's laying down and he looks over and
it's his friend who went to go get help
so this will apparently on the way to
get help he [__] flute went so fast
he flew off somewhere and he smashed his
face face first into a tree
what he said that he like he like lost
his two front teeth no so I'm not
helping anyone
he said look like he got jumped bro so
this phone literally flew off somewhere
and smashed into like a pine tree bro
imagine looking at your you're the homie
that just he's looking at his shoulder
I'm the only one to get help bro you
look over and he goes that's one of the
most embarrassing things so this is what
missing they didn't know where the [__]
he was he got [__] up so he had to get
[__] too because he knocked his teeth
out bro hilarious
so you you lost basically all your
Mobility so what was the what was the
injury so you broke so so basically both
parts of The Tib and FIB that wrap
around the ankle snapped one of them
flipped inside out and that's what stuck
out and then on on this side I don't
know if it's the tip or the FIB it's uh
there's like a piece that pulverized
this much
so it was shattered it was so bad both
sides and then up here so now I have
like a long plate a short plate and I
think 11 screws
it's like bionic that's crazy yeah dude
it's nuts but I mean you could walk I
could walk I've done like like some
running I could skate around I can't
flick my foot so I can't do tricks
because you need that Mobility for it
yeah but um it's crazy because
skateboarding was really one of my
passions and it forever will be like I
still like know a lot about the
community and like we'll watch whatever
but I think it opened the door for me to
be
excited about stuff again you know like
I didn't want to just be like average
anymore I didn't want to just I was very
much so just working cutting 60
appointments a week every week Jesus
Christ 60 cuts a week
and that was like my life I I wasn't
thinking of anything else
and I think with one hobby getting like
taken out of my life
that's when art came in because I
started doing art during the quarantine
and it was like
it filled up like that void in a way you
know like especially because I couldn't
cut hair at the time I just picked up
the pencil and pen or whatever pencil
paper and I was hitting like these
portraits from it that were just like
spot on I was like what the [__] and it
just progressed one piece after another
after another and it sprouted my new
spot which is born from rain Studios
because I was in a drought the art was
the rain and I call it born from rain
that's [__] nuts man I think the
interesting thing is like
so I just had uh somebody come on this
podcast his name is David Nguyen and the
podcast is already out by now but if you
guys haven't watched that podcast go
listen to it it's a really really
inspiring story but it's crazy how
a lot of us need something terrible to
happen for us to really kind of kick
into gear yeah some people are very
self-motivated which is a gift you know
uh a lot of people that I personally
know usually have this route to success
where it takes us to get kicked so bad
to go to the bottom to want us to reach
the top reach the top so for in his case
his sister died
uh in a car accident you know and he
went through a lot of trials and
tribulations where
um was homeless for a little bit he was
pursuing a life in culinary just a lot
of bad ship happening he got scammed he
was out in the streets you know going
back home with his head down you know
failing multiple times over and over and
over again and he was feeling down on
himself like feeling like [__] thinking
that he can't do anything right
um the next thing you know his you know
his sister dies in a car accident and
after that point he was like I don't
have time to waste no I gotta make [__]
happen and it it's it's sad but it's
also one of those sobering reminders of
how short life is and I don't think
people really understand that [__] uh
and I say it a lot on this podcast that
you know you really only get one life
and there's one thing there's a lot of
like second chances that you get at
things right but you know when people
say you get a second chance in life it's
not really true you literally have one
you literally have one life You Gotta
Die that's it I mean if you're religious
you know you go to heaven you have
something that's um that you're gonna
look forward to after
which is understandable but your time on
this Earth is very [__] limited and
I'm not saying that you use this time to
constantly grind 24 7. I'm saying that
you use this life to kind of make your
life worth it while you're still here
and I see that a lot nowadays because
um I think for us I see my parents
getting older you know my mom's uh 70
now and then my dad's in his 60s and
every time I get to go back home I look
at their face like oh they aged that's
the wildest feeling man I remember
college
it was a that was the longest period
that I really wasn't looking to see my
parents and it would be months like
months to who knows how long that
feeling is just a super trippy feeling
and you're just like I need to
appreciate everything for what it is
because you never know
this podcast is brought to you by better
help my friends listen if you are out
there and you are in a space of mental
mental anguish that's where better help
comes in I've been using better help for
quite a while now and guess what it is
the best it's like having a therapist
right in my stinky little pocket and I
love it so much uh for those of you out
there who haven't tried therapy you have
absolutely nothing to lose give it a try
I know there's a lot of people out there
that might feel a certain way they might
feel like oh I don't have any issues
well guess what it's just great to be in
a safe space where you can go ahead and
have a conversation honestly with
somebody that could help you navigate
the treacherous treacherous path that
life has created for you if you're
thinking of giving therapy a try better
help is a great option it's convenient
flexible affordable and entirely online
just fill out a brief questionnaire to
get matched with a licensed therapist a
switch therapist anytime for no
additional charge if you want to live a
more empowered life therapy can get you
there visit betterhealth.com genius
today to get 10 off your first month
that's better help help.com genius
NBA fans it's time to bring the Hoops
action to the palm of your hand with
DraftKings sportsbooks and official
sports betting partner of the NBA this
week new customers can bet five dollars
and win two hundred dollars in free bets
instantly I freaking love that plus for
a limited time all new and existing
customers can get a no sweat same game
parlay every day [__] yeah go to the
DraftKings Sportsbook at today opt in
and place a same game parlay on any NBA
game and if it doesn't hit you'll get a
free BET
back baby listen I'm always gonna bet on
my Kings baby I don't give a [__] I live
out in L.A King's all the way light the
beam they're gonna make me some guap
super super mucho money this year I
swear if you're not a Kings fan I
[__] hate you if you're an LA fan
that's okay still get that bet parlay
and make that skrilla baby we'll see
who's gonna come up download the app now
and sign up with the code genius new
customers can bet five dollars on the
NBA and get 200 in free bets instantly
only at DraftKings Sportsbook an
official sports betting partner of the
NBA with code genius minimum age and
eligibility restrictions apply void in
Ohio C show notes for details
this time of year everyone's talking
about making big changes which is all
well and good but most of the time
pretty unrealistic I've actually found
that the smallest changes to your
routine can make the biggest impact in
the same way and you don't have to break
the bank to make a big deal purchase
even the smallest things can be a part
of a big change it is something that you
use every day like my mother sucking
raycons if I'm working out if I'm
walking if I'm out here doing crazy
crazy boy stuff I have my raycons in my
ears because they're super light compact
the charge lasts forever which a lot of
earbuds don't do and they don't break my
bank which is why I love them
everybody's like yo what's that in your
ear I'm like listen I'm not a secret
agent it's my raycon earbuds and I know
I look sexy and you want me but I'm
married now back up raycon is premium
audio at the perfect price point so you
can build great habits without breaking
the bank my friends three customizable
sound profiles earbud earbud earbud tap
functions noise isolation awareness this
mode custom gel tips for the perfect
most comfortable in-ear fit ready to buy
something small with a big impact go to
buy recon.com brain today to get 15 off
your raycon order that's by raycon.com
brain to score 50 off by raycon.com
and I look at my you know because when I
forget too when my grandparents passed
those were my parents parents it was
Grandma Grandpa to me but that was my
mom exactly and that's a feeling and an
emotion that they had to go through and
they were at an age that was you know
not my age now but close to it where
they had a deal with their death my mom
my mom's mom passed away when I was nine
years old I believe nine or ten years
old yeah so you know let's say I have a
kid
um next year right that's only 10 years
from then that maybe my mom will pass
yeah and these are like very sobering
thoughts people don't think about this
stuff yeah you know because I think it's
just easier because I'm afraid yeah yeah
we ignore it right but time is very
fleeting it's crazy how
in our age so like from one all the way
to like I say till you're I don't know
like 22. you'll see so much
transformation right and then from like
22 23 all the way till you're about like
35 everything is relatively the same the
way you look
um your youth everything stays the same
and then once you hit about 40 50 60
it's like it goes back to that moment
when you were one all the way to 23
where things start where things are
changing rocks but it's super fast I
look at my mom's face it's a little
saggier I see um
um Like the Way She Moves is a little
bit slower uh just look it doesn't look
like the the face that I remember you
know and that's a sobering feeling for
me where I'm like okay I have to make
this time count because there's going to
be a time when she passes and I'm going
to look back and say oh I want to call
my mom and there's nobody to talk to
that is so big and I think about that
often and
things that I recommend people to do is
just take
take action and hit up their loved ones
that are getting older and just like
really appreciate it for what it is like
my relationship with my parents has
improved in the last like few years 100
fold because of that feeling just
enjoying them for when they're here yeah
and I was hello come say hi come say hi
hello
um
Joe go ahead go in the garage okay but
that's my wife everybody yeah she just
got done with yoga
go out the garage
stupid idiot
dude no the door wasn't closed I love
you
dude yoga my mom picked up yoga Hot Yoga
she's doing Bikram Yoga too yeah Bikram
Yoga I that changed my mom's life she
would do two classes back to back in her
late like 50s early 60s my mom could
hold a two 230 plank that's crazy my mom
is like getting younger as it's kind of
lit I'm like thank you good [__] did you
see that documentary about the pictures
yes the guy's sauce everyone needs to
check that out why why the [__] is it
that with anybody who who starts a cult
they somehow end up with the same
conclusion it's like listen I have to
[__] you
literally every goal every [__] call
I forgot I'm like traveling yeah I went
through every binge I was ever since
that one I binged other clothes and it's
the same it's the same ending it's if
you want Enlightenment I I have to suck
on my dick
why why is it why is that the case I
don't know except the bedroom it's in a
speedo
worse it was crazy because he was lit I
think he impregnated a few people too it
was bro it was gnarly yeah that's why
it's called Hot Yoga now
oh see that's why the name changes yes
when you start seeing Edward it was
because that started coming to light
he's not is he alive
I think he ran away I don't know if he's
dying hiding or something he like ran
away to wherever and she just has hella
money
like watching what people
it's it's like kind of like how um
I'm starting a cult
listen you want Enlightenment I need a
nut in your mouth
that is literally a key to life oh my
God yeah it's like it's like a guy comes
in got it no no not you no not you you
can't you're going to help you can't
reach Enlightenment
I saw what you did yeah I had like a
thick Indian like Punjabi accent or
something crazy
I don't know because
and the craziest part they always look
like some [__]
King [__] they're not some
actor ass [__] they are like
the freaking funniest looking
[__] out there it's like if
this guy came up to me right and he was
like listen I want you to know I have
the key to life like listen get the [__]
away from me right and you have to [__]
me like no that's not going to happen
bro
damn man but it just goes to show what
psychological abuse can reach I mean
when you when you find people who are in
very dark places they will find and
rationalize anything as like a sign from
God right and I think that
um a lot of people when they come
towards religion
this is how they do it yeah like they're
at a really dark place and they say
listen
if you give me the best head I've ever
received in my life
will reach this other level of
Enlightenment and you you've tried
everything else it hasn't worked why not
make me a cup no we're good imagine
imagine like all right I'ma just do it
because I believe in this you do it and
then you're like
but it didn't work for you sorry about
that I actually just saw have you seen
this uh do you remember this guy he was
this dude that was recorded on the news
because he stopped a robbery from
happening oh he's like the ax yeah it's
a bang bang that guy yes
try to watch it you should watch the
dock right so apparently this was news
and I didn't know about this but he was
he's actually in jail right now
for murder
he [__] murdered somebody
brutally murdered someone like he wasn't
stopping someone he actually just he
murdered the [__] out of so I'm talking
about his ear was torn off so so the guy
I won't tell you who the guy is but
that's a huge part of it but the guy
that he murdered he brutally destroyed
him and it was it was news I didn't know
about that I just remember him from the
meme that Meme was everywhere people
were making songs with his voice
everything right so the interesting part
about this document and you're gonna
find out and this is my interpretation
of it was
um
they basically go through this whole
story about how he was the dude that
stopped this robbery from happening
right so there was like a car accident
he comes in he gets his ax and he starts
beating the [__] out of somebody with
that ax yeah and he's marked as a hero
yeah this dude is like this weird hippie
he was on the Jimmy Kimmel show he was
on all this stuff
he was The Hitchhiker The Hitchhiker
with the Heart of Gold yup and um people
would come up to him take pictures with
him or whatever well he got arrested for
murder that he got charged for it he's
still in jail now and he's still trying
to make an appeal saying that that guy
raped him but there's clearly absolutely
no evidence that he was raped and there
and the guy that he basically assaulted
he was like 70 or 80 years old oh [__]
so this he's saying claiming that that
guy was it bigger
yeah
let's go yeah which is fine appeal works
yeah that's crazy 70 year old yeah
that's a really old guy and he was a
lawyer too and everybody knew him in
this neighborhood this really sweet guy
and there's like videos of him at like
this train station before the murder
with the with the ax guy Kai his name is
Kai and then he's like hugging him
saying thank you or whatever because he
gave him money or something else or like
a train ticket but basically he murders
that guy in his house and he's putting
an appeal saying that it wasn't murdered
he was raped so it was self-defense but
when you look at the evidence of what
happened at the crime scene there's
usually when you have self-defense and
you hear this a lot of times if you
listen to a lot of true crime stories
that there's nail marks there's
scratches some type of something and his
body is unscathed whatsoever and he said
he got raped
and then he tried to fight him off but
it's like if you got raped and you're
trying to fight him off
um nothing happened to you literally so
it doesn't make any sense but this kid
this guy's [__] weird dude I can't
wait to watch this was my girl and I
were like about to click on it and then
we it's interesting right and the reason
why it's interesting for me is because
I'm not sure if a lot of people took
away from this from what I read from the
reviews but maybe it's because it's what
I do for a living they're interviewing a
bunch of people who are telling their
stories about it so once he became an
internet sensation there was a news
reporter that wanted to make him famous
and obviously for his own career too
because he goes I am the only person
that has ever interviewed him I'm known
as that guy and you could tell as this
guy is telling the story he's he's like
happy that he's the only person that got
to interview him he's like hyped and
Juiced for it right and the thing that I
took away from this is that Kai was
already mentally unstable since the
beginning and all these people who
wanted to put him on TV put him on a
reality TV show you exploited him you
made him into a monster they gave him
this God healing there was a moment in
the dock that you're gonna see and like
I said people I don't think anybody
picked this up where he goes
um I I told Kai that you can either
come with us and I'll make you into this
reality TV star Kai flips a coin he goes
no the coin says I should just go
skateboard and surf and that's all he
cared about but there was a moment where
the reporter says don't you know you can
be famous and then something turned into
something flipped he goes oh I could
take advantage of the stuff because he
was just living life like a crazy person
he would have just been a crazy like
eccentric weird hitchhiker just going
around
and he wouldn't take money he would give
people things or whatever the moment
that he knew he had power as a famous
person he felt that a lot of things were
owed to him and after they kind of
chewed him up and spit him out and go
he's crazy he's useless they set this
Maniac into the world none of these
people that guy who's a reporter looked
like he was talking about like the love
of his life that he had before it was
like I'm known as the guy who's a
reporter that made him famous and he's
like literally living he's doing it and
I saw it I'm like every person in there
you guys should all go to jail with him
you made him into this [__] creature
and you take no response and they're all
talking like they're [__] victims
like none of you are victims you made
him into this [__] creature and you
take no responsibility for it every
person who was on that document you
should all be ashamed of yourself I
can't I literally need to see this
that's crazy so all of them are featured
in the documentary they're like oh he's
crazy and I was the person that was
running the show and I was telling like
yeah like I thought he was a really
sweet person and you know he could have
been the next biggest thing and I'm like
so you're still talking about him as if
he's an opportunity yeah for your job
for your career those guys that guy
specifically is a sick [__] and he's
sitting there thinking oh I still can't
believe it no you played a huge part in
this and the way you talk about it is as
if you miss the biggest opportunity in
your life you're not looking at it as oh
this guy murdered somebody and I
basically essentially incentivize this
person to do this stuff not that it's
your actual fault but you played a hand
in this because you wanted to exploit a
human being rather than looking at the
danger and the possibility of this kind
of being an instability because he knew
he was insane he knew he was nuts he
would walk out it's like clear he would
just walk out and just start pissing on
[__] uh and he was a raging alcoholic
so he was drunk all the time pissing on
pissing on people and ax he was smashing
somebody's head open with an ax and I
think people got caught up in his
verbiage because he was saying things um
that made him famous so for example when
he was recording he goes I just want to
say that no matter who you are out there
you deserve to be loved that you're
worthy and so people took that small
little bite and they summed up who his
character was as a person
but he's actually mentally unstable he's
mentally [__] unstable and so they um
yeah I won't ruin anything else but
you're gonna you guys you get to see his
mom you get to hear all these weird
little storms so his mom so basically
essentially I mean I guess I'm not gonna
really ruin it that much because you're
gonna watch and you'll still be shocked
his mom has an interview and she bait
and she goes on
um telling people what he was like when
he was younger but how he tells his
story is very dark and it's a very
different interpretation of what his
mother says and his mother looks pretty
normal like a normal sweet white lady
and so he has an interview that the
reporter didn't release and he goes I
couldn't put this on the news but I have
this clip and they put it in the video
and basically he's regaling a story
about he about him when he was younger
how he used to get punished punished and
sexually assaulted and locked into a
room and a cloud they wouldn't like feed
him it was something very hyperbolic he
was exaggerating a lot of things yeah
and the only reason why we know this
because mom was like no I didn't do that
he goes he was a very eccentric kid he
was odd so I would put him in timeouts
in his room
so yeah like he would hurt himself so I
would have to keep him in his room it
was it wasn't a basement or a dungeon or
a closet it was his bedroom and he was
saying completely the opposite like he
was like some trouble yeah so you know
he lives in this very odd world and so
we nobody knows whether he's telling the
truth or not but from what his mom says
and his mom's not acting out being
outlandish she goes no like yes he was a
very eccentric child so he would hurt
himself so what I had to do as an
apparent as any parent would do was make
sure that he was safe so yeah I would
like ground him in his room but that's
not me locking him in a closet or
anything but so interesting which goes
towards the end where he talks about him
being you know sexually assaulted by the
70 year old guy yeah sometimes it
doesn't make sense
dog it's it's weird man oh people
pathological Liars are very real have
you have you ever met somebody who was
like a habitual pathological liar yes
weird huh it's weird because
I hey you out here yeah I cut everyone
who knows you bro yeah they tell me the
truth yeah
about that's how I felt and I I just
I didn't want to like get into it with
him or anything
but hearing something and just as a
barber you kind of know everyone I know
the truth yeah and it's not like
you versus one other person it's like
everyone's like no that's not the case
crazy bro there's there's some people
who lie so often and so much that they
start to believe their own yeah that's
exactly what he was you know and I I
told a story on a podcast recently but
you know there was somebody who was like
that where there was two people it was
me and somebody else who knew the same
story and the way that he would describe
his involvement in it was very odd
because we were there and then my other
friend who's very he's like if you think
I'm blunt and straightforward this guy's
10 times worse than I am he doesn't give
a [__] feels like calling him a Liars
like you're full of [__] like the [__]
are you talking about but as I watched
him defend himself it wasn't even it
didn't look like he got caught in his
lie he was so offended because he's like
he believes it he goes like what the
he's like arguing what the [__] are you
talking about and I'm like wait I was
there too and he lies he does it so
often he's told that story to people so
often that he almost forgets the truth
he forgets the truth he made me feel
like maybe I don't know what I'm talking
about am I crazy yeah it's like am I
nuts maybe I didn't see it correctly
right it's scary and these like
pathological Liars are very interesting
I knew a guy in high school who was like
that who would lie so [__] often and
by the way the person that called him
out was also the same guy he just this
guy he's a really close friend of mine
he's he doesn't let any [__] slide so he
would do things uh along the lines and
and by the way when he went to college
the people that he knew in college that
live with him I met them and they also
cut him out because he was such a
habitual liar so it followed him
constantly tough man how do you fix it
he somehow got married to somebody still
I don't know how the [__] that happened
but um what high level narcissist a
habitual liar in high school he would
say [__] like um so for example
he got this uh he's at the time when the
Xbox first dropped he would be like oh I
got an Xbox and so my buddy who likes to
call him out on his [__] he goes
cool so I'm gonna come over to uh I'm
gonna come over after school and check
it out he goes on and on like you can't
come over he goes why and he was like oh
now I can't come over he's like all
right let me ask your sister if I can
come up your parents are cool with me
I'm gonna come over either way he goes
no it didn't come in yet
that's so annoying why do you do that
why do you do that and then on top of
that he would do some [__] like um
oh so he had like this brand new car it
was a Scion tC and at the time when the
Scion tC dropped it was amazing and you
know we were all because of Fast and
Furious were actually cars yeah and so
my buddy he had this Honda Accord and uh
when his son when he had a Scion tC you
know we were a bunch of broke high
school kids grew up in a not so great
Ariel all of us were poor so when you
have a brand new car that wasn't a used
car that's not a lease that your parents
bought you yeah it's dope it's a big
deal so he got this car and he goes oh I
got a turbo for it right uh and of
course my friend chimes in all right
he goes he goes well oh I haven't
installed it yet he goes yep I want to
see it so I'm gonna go to your house
and he goes oh no no you can't my sister
just got this this new dog so like it's
kind of crazy at the house she doesn't
want anybody coming so this is another
lie a liar and they're alive and they're
alive so literally as we're at lunch he
gets his phone he calls his sister in
front of him he goes so you got a new
dog and she goes no what the [__]
bro what is his face he's just like uh
uh uh he goes oh you know I'm just
[__] with you guys
this dude starts going in on him he goes
dude you [__] lie so much about your
[__] [__] but he would just do
that constantly use a homie uh not by
the time oh okay not my friend like he
wasn't my friend like I would like
we're just like mutual friends or
whatever right the only one time that I
almost socked him was like
he knew that I wasn't trying to get in
trouble at school and I think like with
people like that they try to take
advantage of you a lot so if I ever got
into a fight it was after school because
in school my parents would know and my
parents would [__] you up so I was in
high school and then one he just came up
and he socked me in my arm he's got a
small guy he's like my size and I just
looked at him and I'm like okay stop and
he just socks me on multiple times and
I'm like bro you know after school I'm
gonna [__] [__] you up well he's like
whoa I'm just joking around I'm just
playing around it's like no
after school we're gonna fight because
you know I'm not gonna fight you in
school that's why you're stalking me
right now like I'm not gonna swing back
at you because if I get in trouble here
my parents will literally be my inch of
my of my life whatever you do to me in
here my parents will literally kill me
yeah right so he was just one of these
dudes that would just couldn't stop
lying and it was so weird that's why and
for me growing up my dad used to beat my
ass for lying so being around that used
to it's irks you because you're like bro
why aren't you not getting these
repercussions tied to it especially
because the way he would lie he would
lie to make us feel bad about what we
had
you know if I had something nice you
would have you would have to have
something nicer and it's not like we're
poor yeah why do you have to compare
he's like Borat in his um freaking
neighbor you got the iPhone he got iPod
mini
that was for girls
that's what these [__] girls yeah
bro
Jesus man [__] that guy yeah I mean and
it's fun so I went back to Sacramento
not that long ago it was for a wedding
and we met a mutual friend and I was and
he mentioned him he's like oh do you
remember this guy listen of course I
[__] who doesn't [__] remember him
like everybody thought he was super
annoying because yeah I mean we still
kick it like he's he's you know he's a
decent guy and I'm like okay that's cool
I'm not gonna be friendship he goes but
you know it's it's hard to be around him
sometimes like why is it because he
still lies about everything and I'm like
why are you friends how could you
tolerate that as a grown ass person I
don't understand too wouldn't you like
for anybody who's young out there if
you're listening to this and if you're
in college or you're around a group of
people listen once you leave High School
in college if there's bad people in your
life you don't you don't have to be
around them there's no obligation right
these people will drag you and suck your
energy out especially somebody like that
who every step of the way they have to
make themselves look good and push you
down those people are the worst worst
the worst every time you have something
this is a great sign
when you're successful at something and
your friends throw like Jabs at you for
being successful that is already a a red
flag huge record because they're trying
to guide their hate with jokes right
so I hate that [__] if you're with that
concern a hundred percent like if you're
doing something I don't know if that's
gonna work out man yeah are you for
reals or are you just saying that
because you're just being a [__] no I
hate that bro I remember yeah no it's
bad yeah I don't think I'll get it too
it's so bad I hate that I don't really
like you have to strike anyone watching
this has to stray away from that because
then you're just not gonna go for things
out of some fake fear like from like
someone who doesn't mean [__] to you in
10 years 100 seriously uh that's the
hard part where there's some people who
are in your closed Circle who will who
have that right to come into your life
and give you this and give advice but
there's some people who are on the
periphery we're not at that type of
level for you to even step in and lay
your opinion about anything that I do
especially when you're not talented at
all when the person who has zero Talent
who has taken no risk likes to comment
about your risk
it pisses me they go oh that's not going
to be worth it oh for reals you weren't
at the same shitty job for 10 years that
you complain about every day I don't
think you could tell me about what is
what a good business move is or not yeah
so the moment you move out of your mom's
basement you stop jacking off the
Japanese porn then come talk to me all
right you little hentai [__] let's start
with that [__]
and I've had to have these conversations
where you know I think that
if they remember who you were in high
school they don't they they always have
the specific image image and they forget
look we're adults now and I'm gonna say
[__] that's on my mind because I don't
have to [__] with you if I don't want to
yeah so we had
um
basically there was this a get-together
with a bunch of friends and I might have
told the story in the podcast but I
every year somebody gets cut out right
because their true colors will always
show and I still have my really core
group of friends and I still [__] with
them
this person is not one of those guys got
you
um so we're chilling we're drinking
having a good time and then out of
nowhere he just goes oh you know um he
goes you know you're successful because
of like the [__] that we taught you when
we were younger and I looked at him and
it paused and I was already irritated
because I don't like people taking away
from my hard work right and I said I was
like what do you mean it's like I heard
you use some of our jokes from back in
the day I was like so what you are you
asking for a [__] royalties like what
the [__] are you asking for Like This Is
Us [__] around and joking so I'm
telling stories about our past he was
like yeah but like you want to be
successful without all the [__] that we
did for you and everybody else is quiet
it's like weird right and when people go
weird it's like what the [__] and I
looked at him I was like I was like
don't you still sell women's makeup for
a living you little [__]
I was like so I was like I don't think
you get to talk to me about anything and
then you know what he's like trying to
roast back and the last thing I told him
I was like so how's it still like living
with your mom do you do you also [__]
her too at this point because you've
lived with her for so [__] long you
might as well just date her dog and he's
just getting really quiet it's going in
because I'm drunk too by the way at this
point right I'm going in on this
[__] right and then this will
have like these gloves with like the cut
out and [__] no I was like you look like
you warm your hands over a garbage can
every night bro get the [__] out of here
and then eventually he just leaves
and then everybody looked at me and
they're like you kind of went in hard on
them I was like well you saw how he came
at me and thought yeah I'm not saying he
wasn't Disturbed dude you [__] him up
and and next the next friends group I
hadn't seen him in a couple of years and
I saw him uh last year and no and so I
saw him last year and let me tell you
something dude his attitude was way
different this time a lot sweeter a lot
Kinder and a lot more jokey which is how
he normally is yeah and so I had to take
him aside and I was like listen man
um you know we're joking around we're
drinking we're having fun right now but
what you did to me the year before was
[__] disrespectful and so why the
[__] did you come at me like that man
he's like yeah honestly you kind of hurt
my feelings too like I thought you went
a little too hard on me I was like you
could say that all you want you started
that [__] we were having a good time and
I I want to know why the [__] you
decided to do that like we're cool
because I gotta squash this face to face
I can't feel weird about you and not get
this stuff over with yeah and so you
know we were talking and once again
every time we made it we're drinking and
then he kind of opened up he was like
yeah it's just like not happy with
myself yes you know and I so I kind of
like took it out on you and I said
that's cool I understand it's still not
fair to me like I've been nothing but
good to you I've never said anything bad
about you we're supposed to be friends
and I know we're not that close but the
relationship that we had back in the day
Still Remains now
how you feel about your personal life
you don't get to protect and get it
projected exactly because when people
talk to you about me and they go yo how
how is he I say good good things and
positive [__] the moment you saw me you
came at me trying to take away my hard
work you could say whatever the [__] you
want you call me fat weird loud
obnoxious all good you never take away
from my hard work because I have mine I
I [__] when I was out here in La none
of you were around right broke as [__]
[__] like 50 of my bank account
dedicating your time eating Top Ramen
every day in my room never [__]
endless nights endless [__] nights
all right hoping that I would pop off
and then you say one thing and you try
to take it away you don't try to credit
it to yourself and even worse and I was
like I'll be real you [__] hurt my
feelings this is why I went so hard on
you dude and I was like also two you
know what I do for a living you think
that was smart yo I was like you thought
you were gonna come up on this you know
what I mean so you know we squashed it
and we talked it man to man and it was
good enough of that we you know we had a
good time and I could I still consider
him a friend
but you know just going back to what
we're talking about how to stand up for
yourself and your work for sure though
that is one thing that
I've I've really like learned is to
believe in you if you believe in
yourself you also have to fight for
yourself too because there are people
that are gonna hate on your ideas that
are gonna think that it's not gonna work
for you whatever and sure if it's true
you still have to like put that aside
and go for it yeah and you know this is
it's not easy for me I think sometimes I
get comments they go I wish I could have
said some stuff like you did David and I
always tell them it's not easy for me
it's super uncomfortable like when I
have to take somebody aside away from
people that's what I'm talking about
it's uncomfortable I feel uncomfortable
all the time I deal with social anxiety
24 7 but I know that if I don't say my
piece now it's gonna bother me and I
don't want to be bothered every time I
see this person so I'm going to say my
[__]
um and it's good to have that honest
relationship because imagine if every
time I said what's up to this fool it
was just awkward as hell right and
sometimes and it's just fake I can't
live like that you're not someone that's
fake that's one thing I've learned from
like our relationship
yeah I really don't [__] care you
know like I care about the people that
are kind to me yep and I'm always great
to the people that I have to be great to
right but if you're somebody I'm not
saying if you cross me I'm just gonna be
disrespectful to you but if you deserve
it you deserve it right and I I
definitely want people to understand
like when they know me it's like listen
I'm always going to be honest with you
right
um I'm gonna be careful with my words
and I'm Gonna Be Kind I'm gonna be very
mindful with my [__] but if you're
asking for somebody to be dishonest with
you and to lie to you all the time it's
just not gonna happen with me I'd rather
just not be around you and there's too
many of that what you just said about
those people who are just like fake or
fake in the sense of like not
being or being dishonest with their
friends it's important to have some like
truths come in as well and there's a
balance yeah we're tact I think that's
what Mario had to find out about me too
where um you know
a lot of our friends they dance around
subjects and she met my family and she
goes oh no nobody here
they're like oh [__] it's like she goes
Spiderman you know so you know there's
things like family politics yeah I don't
know about family politics because my
mom doesn't deal with family politics
he's like oh you got a problem with me
say your [__] you know she squares up
I'll be like I'll see what you got to
say that's my mom too honestly and then
we hash it out because I don't want to
deal with the [__] while sharing a meal
and you're here with a [__] attitude
it's awkward and so with her I saw her
having to move around her family's
emotions and stuff which is smart to a
certain extent because her family is so
big and she saw how my family functions
she goes oh you guys just put it out
there like hey I don't like the way that
you did it so like my mom for example
I didn't eat her breakfast that she made
for me right and I think for most people
they would be I feel like most moms are
kind of like passive aggressive right
they're like oh I guess you're not gonna
eat my mom's like
so what do you hate me
she goes you stopped loving me once you
eat I was like you literally have called
me fat for two days straight I'm not
hungry she goes well you don't come here
often so just eat my food and I'm like
I'm not hungry I'm gonna throw up yeah I
don't want to eat this I'll eat it later
right I'll eat it later when I'm hungry
she goes so just say you hate me oh my
help I'll eat it she goes good just
[__] eat it
that is so funny actually yeah damn we
hash it all out and I I personally love
that right and by the way like I said
it's always with a lot of tact first
until it gets to a point where tact is
just not possible and I think sometimes
people go oh well how come you argue
with people a lot it's not that I argue
with people a lot I think most people
don't know how to speak to people and
address when they're uncomfortable
that's why because I don't want to get
taken advantage of so if I say hey so
for example
um
let's say I don't know I'm hanging out
with somebody I don't know and he goes
um [__] like you know he said
something on a racially insensitive
he'll be like oh you know these [__]
black people they steal all the time
I'll be like hey bro I ain't really cool
with that I know you're making a joke
but there's a little uncomfortable it
makes me uncomfortable yeah you know
I'll say that I'll joke I like Mario
says I'm really good at making
uncomfortable situations comfortable by
adding humor to it so I'll when somebody
annoys the [__] out of me I'll make a
joke about it where everybody can laugh
but they get the message that this is
too much yeah like you need to chill
exactly and I've definitely had to do
that a lot in my past I met my friends
um fiance they're married now and I
first met her I thought she was the most
annoying [__] person on Earth and I
just started going in on her you know
and out of jokes and everybody's
laughing and then he looked at me
afterward he was like
she can get a little crazy sometimes I
was like I know that's why I know you
told me that story too yeah and then she
melted out after that yeah she was chill
now she knows like oh I don't have to
act so crazy around him I don't have to
be funny around David because he's the
funny guy yeah am I exactly you don't
have to do that just chill the [__] out
you know dealing with interpersonal
relationships is hard but you have to do
it you know and I'm pretty sure in your
business too people probably try to take
advantage of you all the time oh man but
honestly I think just being like very
clear about things like you said
if you if you aren't clear if you don't
make things like aware like known that
awkwardness or that like feeling like of
like there's something going on also
holds you back from a lot of things so
just clearing that air so cute I
literally just We're Not Gonna mention
the name right but I uh
so I hooked this one up with one of my
homies that needed a haircut oh my God
this [__] had me dying [__] laughing
right I typically don't recommend a lot
of people to search because he's a busy
guy and I think that you know you've
gotten to the point where your skill set
and your clientele or you get to pick
and choose who you want and when you do
choose somebody you give them the the
best service possible so I was like okay
this guy that I know he's you know
somewhat well known I was like it'll be
a good look for Surge and he needs a cut
so I send him over and the next thing
you know I get a text from Sir she goes
dude I gotta tell you the [__] funny
story oh my God
yeah no I actually that was uh that was
a great
um example of just making things very
clear
I made thing I make everything
transparent in my business and that's
what ended up saving the situation
because and that's that situation where
you get taken advantage of very quickly
you know you gotta tell the story this
is so funny We're not gonna drop names
but just tell the story essentially
I was cutting hair uh and
one I didn't get a clear Direction on
the haircut so I was like
yo like what do you want like this that
I gave some some like options yeah
all right do you want this dot on top
yeah and it was going well chill right
at whatever
then essentially I
go and I'm very much so you know how I
am with my haircuts I'm I'm I tailor
them it's important to like get opinion
or whatever on top of my expertise and
there's one thing that I will not do and
I'll make this clear is I don't use
enhancements just because I've never
been that person because they wash off
they make a haircut look like crisp when
it's not really crisp and so Barbers
will hide behind enhancements
some Barbers will hide behind
enhancements to make a cut pop
when I was like yo
um is this good for this he's like I
need that whatever I was like oh I
actually don't do that and then after
that he's like
yo after I made it clear I texted you I
was like this is what I charge make sure
that is known because I'm never going to
be a barber who puts a line around your
head yo bro I'm gonna charge you eighty
dollars seventy dollars whatever yeah
I'm not gonna be that guy
if you're stepping into my studio it's
an agreement if I'm
I will
be fair yeah I will give you a free
haircut even if it's not like a crazy
mess up I haven't done that in years but
I know I didn't mess someone up I know I
didn't give them a bad haircut and I
gave an option of yo like let's like
talk to me I think they had this
image and I really truly believe it's
because of like how I look and how I
carry myself they think that I was like
privileged or some [__] right they don't
know my story obviously and they're like
man this is this is OD whatever and I
was like
it would be
if I didn't make things clear from the
get-go which by the way so he made it
clear to me to let everything know I
copied and I pasted it over I was like
this is what he charges and this is the
service that you're going to get things
like cool got it and then I reiterate
that with my appointment
I I have no hate none nothing wrong
besides the fact that I felt that it
wasn't fair to me yeah because I was
alone those two people that were in
there and I think they thought that
because of who I was and like how I
carried myself it was going to be a
situation because I've seen it before
where
oh nah bruh
okay let me give you a free haircut when
it's not a wrong like it was actually
very crispy raw I wish I took a picture
of you so I could show you but
I stood my ground even though it's like
you know like it's different leagues in
terms of like what it could happen but I
was just like yeah like this is what it
is
and I think that for Barbara's hearing
just go with his approach you don't have
to pop off until it gets to like
whatever moment but just hold your
ground if you know generally you didn't
mess up
just like tell them how it is and just
speak your truth you know like make it a
like a cordial thing
anyway
um it led to
what was it it was like I asked like
what what their what their people charge
in the like 50 bucks and I think I was
like charging 75 right all right charge
75 at the time
and I was like where does he cut in a
barber shop like yeah I was like in a
barber shop that's actually pretty easy
to upkeep you know you have your booth
rent split the whole rent split between
a bunch of barbers
I'm like in the studio solo and you're
giving a private private haircut when
people say private appointment you walk
in and still like hello people it's like
no I'm genuinely giving a private
service
I don't take people any time and that's
another thing when I was like you can't
fight I told them I was like you can't
find me on Yelp this is genuinely a
vehicle for me to make art and like
pursue that passion and they didn't know
that but like when we say private
haircut come on you're the only person
in there yeah it's like you could say
what you could tell me you murdered
someone it's it's a it's a different
experience like being in a barber shop
with like six other people getting cut
you get your chair turned you're facing
the other dude yeah this is literally
you're they're by yourself with Sergio
it's a private haircut yep which is dope
it was it was and I'm the craziest part
very hard to go back by the way yeah
yeah literally and you know this and I
and from my clients
Pro I know how to cut Asian homies yeah
yeah I'm a beast at Asian hair I
understand it because it's easy to mess
up it's very easy to mess up so I know
what I delivered and I think that's why
I was very much so I gave options like
oh let me know what you want I think the
stubbornness aspect of it like no like
because I didn't have this like this
enhancement spray that was going to wash
off
I think that really turned it around but
just how it is like I don't have to take
them ever again yeah yeah I mean the
cool beauty of like what I do I mean you
stud your ground which is very important
and you didn't budge and you didn't get
pumped which is an admirable thing I
think a lot of people would have folded
and I'm not saying I'm too prideful
either if I messed them up I'm giving
I'm not charging [__] yeah shaking hands
like I'm sorry I wasn't your guy yeah
straight up but yeah I'm just
the hard part too is when I think for me
I always I have a general idea of what I
want but I don't know terminology very
well and then I'll always look at the
barber and say like listen what do you
think is best for my style of hair
because my hair I don't have thick hair
you know I mean like I'm not balding but
I don't my my hair's fine so what is
something that can work for me and then
Sergio's like okay this is what I'm
gonna do this will this is this is what
it is and after a few Cuts he goes
actually this might be better than the
last one and it got better and better
every cut so now we know what is best
and it took a few Cuts exactly your your
hair texture is the same
as like were cut and it's not easy and I
remember making it so like Blended so
well I I don't want to take just because
I this is the only situation in my
entire three years
the only time since I've been or two and
a half years since I've been in that
studio that anything has gone like
sideways yeah so I'm like oh but I kind
of wish I could like do it again just to
be like man let's let's have other
people chime in I want to really hear
you say that this isn't it oh yeah yeah
because I know down like two and a half
years no problems
it says something you know I think you
take a lot of pride in your work right
which um I did like previous Barbers
that I went to before it seemed like it
was just a job for them like it was just
I mean which is fine you could use it as
a vehicle to do other things which is
great but you know when you have this
one-on-one
you were with me for an hour yeah
literally yeah now you got you got to
care about this somewhat and my last
Barber [__] up my hair right he wasn't
picking up calls or whatever and then he
literally the fade was uneven from left
and right and I'm not very picky about
my haircuts by the way right I just know
if I like it or if I don't and he was
okay but the price was right and you
know in the meantime in the beginning
when he didn't have much clients he
would respond back
and he just got comfortable with me
it [__] up my hair and I'm like hey bro
like the hair is not like you see this
right like it's here and here
and he goes oh okay so what do you want
me to do about it I'm like oh my God
what do you mean what do you want what
kind of questions this is so crazy right
and then so I actually know this about
him he was a really cool guy super kind
uh I'm like all right cool I'm like you
know what it's all good so
I hit him up for a haircut he doesn't
respond back and he's texting like you
know what guy like you don't respond
back like you're you're professional
isn't like it's like we're pretty much
done here right and he texted me back he
goes yo I'm good for a cut I was like no
I don't think you understand
I'm not getting America from you I'm not
recommending anybody to you like this is
ridiculous like bro
so late lo and behold it turns out that
he wants to be an actor right so his
he's focusing on acting and not haircuts
which is cool but I already paid money
this is a transaction I paid money I
don't give a [__] about your outside
[__] it's not I'm not your [__] mom
I'm not your dad I know I'm not here to
[__] be like yo go ahead go for your
dreams give me my haircut you know
so you know he's a failed actor now from
I heard through the grapevine right
because I know a couple people know him
like he gave up on acting too he's not
even doing Barber Shop stuff anymore and
the guy's like jobless right now it's
like uh and I just heard about this like
a couple weeks ago and I'm like dude you
half-assed everything in your life you
can't let go of your vehicle to the next
move like yeah people will like be like
Oh I'm gonna go become this thing well
you have to get there still and there's
something that you're doing right now
that's one thing I'm very clear with my
clients like I'm I'm pursuing artwork
and like becoming an artist but you're
still getting the same exact service I
hope you never stop cutting here I'll be
so sad bro don't cut don't stop cutting
until I go bald
Baldi absolutely I'm still gonna get a
lineup for no reason they just cut my
hair for all time's sake there's not
much left that's why I'll bring the
powder out bring the powder out but I'll
just cut something I just do this for a
[__] just because of catch it up yeah
oh yeah well man hey that wraps up this
episode of The Genius brain podcast
Serge where can they find you
um so on Instagram bfr Sergio on YouTube
it's born from rain studio so do you
have any more open clientele right now
right now so I'm actually moving spots
to March 1st it's about to be the
craziest haircut
oh I'm excited in L.A crazy as haircut
in LA
I'm thinking about opening up my books
to new clients for the time being that
way it's going to be like an interview
like if the haircut goes well let's go
to the next spot type thing you know
okay okay it's like the first time I'm
really being so like clear about that
but I'm down to meet I've actually had
people come from the last podcast and I
love them so let's come through try it
out hit me up on Instagram bfr Sergio or
bfr Studios
um and then we'll set you up and yeah
yeah I've yeah I've definitely walked
out and people are like oh [__] yeah I
saw from America that was multiple times
yeah which is great don't [__]
embarrass me all right you're literally
getting an invite through me yeah don't
[__] embarrass me don't do that
stupid [__] dude everybody loves
your [__] Cuts man like I mean
anytime I get to cut people like yo the
Fades [__] clean which by the way
didn't happen before
it's hard man it's hard when you have
like yeah my hair is difficult by the
way like because it's not thick it's
hard to get a really nice
blend so it's different cool so people
will kind of just they'll butcher it
yeah they'll do skin fade and no fade at
all what the [__] just happened here no
head shape none of that exactly so like
if you guys go to surgery please just
just come right please come correct
because it's still me uh do you explain
every Sundays at 12 p.m we'll catch you
all next time peace
[Music]